[Musik]
sie merken es vermutlich zu Hause und
ich merke es auch beim Einkaufen das
Leben in Deutschland wird immer teurer
der Statistische Bundesamt schockte
heute mit neuen Zahlen jeder dritte
Deutsch hat kein Geld für plötzliche
Ausgaben muss ein Kredit aufnehmen für
eine kaputte Waschmaschine oder neue
Bremsbeläge im Auto 63 Prozent aller
deutschen sagen inzwischen unsere
Politiker können keine Krise stimmt das
darüber möchte ich heute abend
debattieren mit diesen Gästen
Medienwissenschaftler Norbert Bolz er
sagt wir müssen endlich lernen richtig
zu streiten ohne ständig in
Moralisierung zu verfallen sie können
sich meine Freude vorstellen als ich die
These gelesen habe denn dafür steht ja
für den nach acht schön dass Sie da sind
auch mit von der Partie der Schweizer
Journalist und Buchautor Philipp gut er
sagt die Freiheit geht verloren der
Staat entmündigt die Bürger auch eine
nicht ganz so fremde Fülle nach
CDU-Politiker und tiktoks da uwe
dohrendorf hat heute einiges vor nämlich
eine Generalabrechnung mit den Grünen
und last but not least der international
bekannte Autor und Journalist Adrian
Geiges er mit dem Steigen Einfluss
Chinas mein Thema heute Abend ist ein
anderes und zwar ist es die
flüchtlingskrise XXL die Deutschland
trifft wer noch vor kurzem sagte dass
dieses Jahr noch mal Flüchtlinge kommen
als 2015 wurde als Schwarzmaler
deformiert doch nun haben wir die harten
Zahlen auf dem Tisch und es sieht gar
nicht gut aus ist ein bis September mehr
Flüchtlinge nach Deutschland gekommen
als im Gesamtjahr 2015 allein aus der
Ukraine wurden fast eine Million
Menschen registriert zusätzlich kam
hunderttausende Flüchtlinge aus Russland
Tunesien dem Libanon und aus Afrika über
die Türkei und die Balkanroute nach
Deutschland schon jetzt fürchte deutsche
Kommunen unterbringungsengpässe im
Winter in Österreich nähern sie die
Zahlen denen des Krisenjahres 2015 meine
erste Frage ist eine Politiker hier in
der Runde Herr dohrendorf schaffen wir
das
das ist schwierig wir sehen uns ja jetzt
eher schon zu Hause in den Gemeinden das
einfach kein Wohnraum erfahren ist wir
sind gerade dabei wir bekommen in
Lüchow-Dannenberg so ca 25 30
Flüchtlinge jede Woche und die werden
dann halt einfach mit dem Bus einfach
ich sage jetzt mal
abgestellt und dann müssen wir sehen wie
wir sie unterbringen es geht jetzt so
weit dass wir wahrscheinlich Turnhallen
wieder herrichten müssen das hat auch
wieder Probleme die Schüler können ihre
ihre ihren unterrichte Sport nicht mehr
machen die Vereine können wieder keine
keine Wettbewerbe durchführen das sind
ja nur die kleinen Probleme aber wir
haben einfach keine keine Wohnung mehr
wir haben jetzt gerade ein ein wirklich
nicht sehr schönes Haus hergerichtet
das haben mal die Chinesen gekauft
tatsächlich und die kriegen jetzt
750.000 im Jahr an
Miete unglaublich weil sie einfach keine
Möglichkeit im moment mal die bekommen
750.000 Euro Miete für ein Jahr ja und
das ein Haus sie haben wie viel
Wohnungen sind denn in dem Haus drin 50
Leute passen da rein für die
Unterbringung 50 Menschen es ist so dass
die was läuft in der falsch es kommt mir
sehr hoch vor wir sind für zweifelt wo
wollen wir sie hinbringen also weil wir
gesagt haben die Turnhallen das ist ja
eine Katastrophe Familien in die
Turnhalle unterzubringen da sind nur
leichte Wände dass er das überhaupt
keine keine
Familienatmosphäre möglich und darum
haben wir gesagt wir müssen es irgendwo
anders machen das Problem ist diese
Chinesen haben ein altes Schlachthaus
gekauft und da waren halt viele Gebäude
dabei und ein Gebäude richtet jetzt
gerade die Gesamtgemeinde her und dann
werden die Flüchtlinge da untergebracht
und dann wird gezeigt der Vertrag läuft
über zwei Jahre
das trifft er direkt die Leute die wenig
Geld haben die bei uns im Land wohnen
zwar ganz egal immer schon Deutsche mit
Migrationshintergrund die sieht ja
gerade die Opfer weil natürlich
Vermieter werden sich sagen ich vermiete
doch lieber für solche Preise an den
Staat als irgendwelchen Familien die gar
nicht so viel bezahlen können da müssen
wir noch mal auf der Spur gehen was da
falsch läuft beim Start also ein
Steuerzahler muss ich sagen 750.000 für
ein Jahr für 50 Flüchtlinge das ist sehr
viel ja
aber aber Herr Geiges wenn ich sie
fragen darf kommen denn da Erinnerung
bei Ihnen an 2015 hoch
naja auf jeden Fall um das Problem ist
ja also ich bin ja sehr dafür dass wir
brauchen ja Menschen aus der ganzen Welt
weil unsere Gesellschaft überaltet aber
das wird überhaupt nicht angegangen es
wird halt die humanitäre Hilfe für das
sind ja nur zum kleineren Teil jetzt
politisch verfolgt aber halt für
Kriegsflüchtlinge und so weiter und so
weiter oder für Leute die aus
wirtschaftlichen Gründen kommen aber das
was eigentlich gebraucht würde dass man
gezielt Leute holt die auch hier was tun
können wir haben sie gerade gesehen
Flughäfen und so weiter ich meine wir
haben so viele Leute obwohl Jobs gibt es
ja genug ich möchte unterbrechen aber
wir haben ja gerade über 500.000 freie
Stellen vor allem auch in einfachen
Tätigkeiten das heißt eigentlich
benötigen wir ja die Flüchtlinge der
Economist hat mal geschätzt dass wir
400.000 Flüchtlinge pro Jahr als
Zuwanderung auch brauchen aber offenbar
wird das falsch organisiert weil sonst
wäre die Jobs besetzt es kommen die
falschen Leute wir haben eine negativ
Selektion
die Zahl in der Schweiz sind so dass von
allen Flüchtlingen 84% Sozialhilfe
beziehen längerfristig also über viele
Jahre Weg nicht einfach am Ende sein 16%
arbeiten nur nur 60% arbeiten alle
anderen sind langfristig vom Staat
abhängig das heißt von anderen
Steuerzahlern von der Nachbarn und das
kann das nicht sein also wir haben eine
völlig blinde Asylpolitik und ich meine
dass das Wort das sozial Tourismus ist
völlig richtig es sind es sind
Wirtschaftsmigranten also sie finden
mehr hätte sich nicht dafür
entschuldigen müssen auf keinen Fall das
ist eine Beschreibung der Realität das
trifft einfach in vielen Fällen zu man
kann sogar noch weitergehen und sagen
das ist ja es hat also das
matratzerisches man kommt Hermann Nüsse
Sozialsystem aus aber ich will nicht mal
unbedingt Flüchtlingen den Vorwurf
machen sondern unser Politik wir sind
dafür verantwortlich dass wir das nicht
so lassen ich habe selbst recherchiert
in China Artikel zum Beispiel auch die
Ausweispflicht oder man kommt normaler
Menschen weisen sich aus beiden jungen
Flüchtlingen unter 18-Jährigen ist so
dass 697% Pass wegwerfen sich gar nicht
richtig ausweisen und wenn Eltern Leib
und Leben verfolgt sind und das ist der
Definition
dann haben sie ein Interesse an die
Identität offenzulegen und offenbar wird
das nicht gemacht das zeigt schon dass
das sehr viel einfach auch betrogen wird
und dass das ist sicher nicht richtig
wenn ich jetzt mal gegen Argument wagen
wollen würde kann es auch einfach sein
dass sowohl Schweiz auch als Deutschland
keine Integration können ich meine die
Menschen sind da die Arbeit ist da sind
wir vielleicht auch einfach zu blöd für
Integration
stehen die herkommen weil es wird alles
bezahlt dass wir in Dolmetscher bezahlt
dass wir dies und das bezahlt
ebensozialausgaben und es ist schon wenn
man ein fremdes Land geht gehen Sie mal
nach China kommt vielleicht auch darauf
gehen sie nach Vietnam und sagen Sie
dort ich liebe diesen Staat leben die
lachen ja nur ich meine das ist schon
eine eine merkwürdige Mentalität
nach Deutschland zum Beispiel 2015 da
habe ich auch mal undercover in einem
Flüchtlingsheim gearbeitet und da muss
ich ihn ganz ehrlich sagen aus meinen
Erfahrungen damals auch die Menschen die
arbeiten wollten die durften ja gar
nicht weil das ist ja auch ganz
bürokratisch hier in unserem Land es
gibt ja auch Flüchtlinge die zu uns
kommen und die einfach nicht dürfen ich
hoffe bei Ukrainern geht das jetzt
schneller da würde ich gerne Herr
dohrendorf fragen was ich da verbessert
hat ja leider wir mein großes Problem
und zwar ist es halt so man muss
arbeitslos sein damit man diesen diesen
Deutschkurs mitmachen kann der kostet
1000 bis 2000 €. wenn ich nicht
Arbeitslosen darf ich Dir nicht machen
wir haben aber genügend Leute die würden
20 Stunden gerne arbeiten in der Pflege
in anderen Bereichen weil sie auch zu
Hause in der Pflege oder in ihrem
Berufen gearbeitet haben dürfen sie aber
nicht weil sie sonst diesen Kurs nicht
umsonst bekommen und das und das ist ein
Unding also warum man das so so so
formuliert aber das ist so typisch
deutsch das ist nicht zu Ende gedacht
wenn ich also ein ein Job habe bis 450
Euro darf ich das aber wenn ich 20
Stunden arbeite geht's eben nicht und
das funktioniert eben nicht weil wir
genügend Stellen haben die wir besetzen
wollen als Medienwissenschaftler wie
blicken sie auf die flüchtlingskrise und
wie berichten wir auch die Medien
darüber
ja ich denke und sie haben das ja schon
angesprochen es gibt eben doch in
Deutschland eine sehr sehr tiefgehende
Ängstlichkeit Probleme der Integration
anzusprechen und die Medien sind leider
Gottes nicht auf der Seite der
Aufklärung was das betrifft wie in
vielen anderen Themenbereichen ja leider
auch also wir haben gerade was das Thema
Migration Massenmigration betrifft auch
aus historischen Gründen sehr viele
Tabus bei der Thematisierung und das
macht natürlich das bürokratische
abwickeln solcher Probleme
außerordentlich schwierig ich sehe es
genauso wie Sie dass es eben nicht nur
Wirtschaftsflüchtlinge gibt die dann
womöglich tatsächlich nur Hartz IV oder
irgendetwas einstreichen wollen sondern
sehr viele Leute die auch gerne arbeiten
würden und durchaus auch qualifiziert
sind und das ist ein bürokratischen
Problemen scheitert aber ich denke wir
kommen wirklich nur weiter wenn wir da
bin ich fast schon bei meinem eigenen
Thema von heute wenn wir das auch
tatsächlich diskutieren die Probleme
diskutieren offen ansprechen und nicht
so der auf dieses Problem hinweist
sofort als Nazi abkanzeln denn das ist
ja das große Problem dass gerade
Massenmigration bei uns mit dem wenn Sie
so wollen Nazi Tabu belegt ist also
jeder wird dagegen ist gegen eine
vollkommene Offenheit also ein
vollkommene Grenzenlosigkeit des
zuwandern
recht weiter
ich meine wir hatten gerade den Tag der
Deutschen Einheit und erstaunlich viele
Leute haben zugegeben das hat mich
wirklich überrascht also von Politikern
genauso wie von Journalisten dass wir
selten in diesem Land seit dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg so gespalten werden also dass
die Spaltung der Gesellschaft selten so
groß war und ich denke der Grund dafür
ist dass wir
vollkommen verlernt haben zu streiten
dieses die Möglichkeit zu streiten setzt
natürlich eine gewisse Zivilisiertheit
Urbanität Höflichkeit also bürgerliche
Tugenden voraus aber wenn man heute die
großen Themen der Politik anschaut
Massenmigration aber natürlich auch die
Klimakrise Corona ein schreckliches
Beispiel für mein Problem mein Thema
dann sehen wir das gar nicht diskutiert
wird es wird gar nicht gestritten
sondern die Gegenposition also die Leute
die Abweichen vom Mainstream der
durchgesetzt wird von der politischen
medialen Elite diese Gegenposition wird
diabolisiert für dämonisiert das sind
dann die bösen das sind die ewig
Gestrigen wenn es gut läuft die
reaktionäre eben letztlich dann auch die
Nazis und dieses dieser slippery slope
dass Sie wenn Sie eine abweichende
Meinung äußern zu irgendeinem großen
bedeutenden Thema sie dann Abrutschen
sehr sehr schnell in der öffentlichen
Wahrnehmung in der Darstellung in der
Öffentlichkeit in dieses
rechtsaußenlager das ist unser
eigentliches Problem denn das bringt die
Menschen die anderes denken und andere
Themen haben und Thesen haben zum
Verstummen und deshalb haben wir es
erstmal persönlich erlebt dass sie
selbst verstummt sind oder nicht mehr
eingeladen wurden oder nicht mehr
eingeladen natürlich unendlich oft das
das ist klar da muss man aber aufpassen
dass man nicht mit persönlicher
Gekränktheit das Thema überfrachtet
deshalb will ich das nicht thematisieren
aber der andere Punkt
Stammgast bei ARD ZDF aber vielleicht
liegt es auch an meinem fortschreitenden
Alter dass man Beispiel also eingeladen
aber ich hatte euch natürlich auch nicht
das ist am Alter liegt Nominierung ich
hatte schon sehr sehr deutlich den
Eindruck vor allen Dingen was viel
interessanter war ich habe mir nebenbei
immer auch ein bisschen Geld verdient
bei Veranstaltungen in der Wirtschaft
und mit dem ersten Wort dass ich gegen
Merkels Migrationspolitik geäußert habe
ist das abgebrochen von heute auf morgen
also es kam überhaupt keine Einladung
mehr und das hat mich nicht besonders
geschmerzt und alteriert aber es war
deutlich ähnlich wie bei ARD und ZDF da
kam plötzlich gar nichts mehr und da
hatte ich schon sehr deutlich den
Eindruck hey wenn du dich da deutlich
artikuliert passiert das und das und
vielleicht nur noch eine Ergänzung dazu
die Leute haben dann auch festgestellt
die mein Twitter-Account mal überprüft
haben und so ich hätte mich in den
letzten Jahren radikalisiert und diese
Radikalisierung hat natürlich auch ein
ganz simplen Hintergrund nämlich ich
wurde pensioniert und die Pensionierung
war ich plötzlich unergreifbar und
konnte sagen was ich wirklich denke ich
habe also gar nicht anders gedacht als
früher
ich war auch lange an der Uni und viele
Professoren die sind kritisch hinter den
Kulissen aber es ist so eine
Hinterzimmer Offenheit aber die Kamera
geht es vorbei ich habe das selbst schon
nicht in Deutschland
mit dem ehemaligen bayerischen
Innenminister Hermann über Kriminalität
Ausländer gibt es da Zusammenhänge
natürlich gibt es statistisch
nachgewiesen vor der Sendung hat der
Vollgas gegeben dann ging die Kamera an
und auf Sendung weiter weg hat das
Gegenteil von dem erzählt was vor und
das finde ich schon seit meine
politische Politiker tun könnte
bestimmte Verortung in der Politik das
verstehe ich nicht man wählt ja
Politiker für ihre Meinung die müssen
Kante geben und nicht für einen
nichtmeinung oder eine schwankende meine
Politik verstehen
auch erlebt ich habe zum Silvester ein
Video veröffent Personen haben sie
angesprochen was ganz krass war diese
extreme Mainstream und hatte der Chef
von Ringe Schweiz marc falder hat ein
Video im Geheimen gemacht vor einer
Wirtschaftselite und ich habe das dann
gelegt und dann sagt eben dass er alle
Redaktionen weltweit von Ringe
angewiesen habe regierungstreu zu
berichten
das sind Verschwörungstheoretiker die
Idioten da die das Gefühl haben das ist
gesteuert von oben jetzt sagt der
mächtigste medienpost in der Schweiz
international tätig eben das man müsste
regierungszahl sein hatten sogar Bild
angegriffen dass ein Link jetzt so zu
Ihnen hier hat Bild angefert Design aber
schon ganz radikal Design sogar kritisch
oder so kritisch sein ist nicht mehr
erlaubt es wird von oben durchgedeckt
das ist ein extremes Beispiel aber es
gibt auch das viel schlechter als
Deutschland
Alexander Kister der oft zu Gast ist von
der Endzeit
musste sie entschuldigen bei Bild das
ist ja attackiert hat aber das ist nur
ein Klaus das Beispiel es gibt auch die
Scheren im Kopf das erlebe ich sehr
stark als das Auto ist journalistisch
trauen das zu schreiben und dann
hinterher oder wir haben immer gesagt
früher bei der Weltwoche wo ich lange
stehe für Tag zu war wir bringen die
Themen alle Lymphen die Nase oder halten
sich die Nase zu ah ganz schlimm und
zwei Jahre später kommt als NZZ mit dem
seitenfular und schreibt das gleiche
also es braucht immer eine gewisse Zeit
du musst einfach den Mut haben die
Meinung zu vertreten aber die Frage aber
die kleine Korrektur die ich gerne
anbringen würde an ihren Beobachtung die
ich sonst 100%ig unterstreiche gerade
als ich das erwähnt habe mit der
Pensionierung und der Freiheit des
Alters wenn sie so wollte der freien
Meinung die man dann äußern kann ist mir
eines klar geworden wäre ich in dem
Augenblick nicht 65 gerade gewesen
sondern 35 hätte ich dann dasselbe
getwittert hätte ich dasselbe
geschrieben schon gesagt jetzt und ich
verstehe jeden
Assistenten jeden Menschen der am Anfang
seiner wissenschaftlichen Karriere ist
so wie ich mittlerweile auch viele
Journalisten verstehe nicht Politiker da
gebe ich Ihnen Recht aber bei den
Journalisten und Wissenschaftlern die
noch jung sind am Anfang ihrer Karriere
und die im Grunde merken dass sie mit
einem falschen Wort und zu starken
Formulierung
setzen bei denen kann ich das sehr gut
verstehen und ich wäre ich will mir
nicht es ist eine Frage des Mutes da
haben sie recht aber wenn jemand eine
Familie zu ernähren hat wenn jemand
tatsächlich noch nicht gesichert ins ist
in seiner Karriere und seine Existenz
kann ich verstehen dass sie wenigstens
still sind und klein bei geben und
schlimm ist es nur dass und das bei den
Politikern in der Tat der Fall dass bei
Leuten die eigentlich von Berufswegen
eigentlich ihre Meinung verändern soll
wenn die genauso pushen wie
reinholen und natürlich mit der Frage es
wurde jetzt gerade schon gesagt bei
Politikern ist es Verständnis sehr
gering wenn man vor der Talkshow den
starken Mann macht und dann in der Talk
so leise ist habe ich auch schon mal
erlebt aber was ich sie fragen möchte
wie sehen Sie das denn in der Politik
sagt jeder was er denkt nein viele
Stimmen ja auch im Namen der Partei ab
also nur für die Parteien großes Problem
und damit habe ich am Anfang ein großes
Problem gehabt das schöne ist ich bin
seit 36 Jahren selbstständig bin völlig
unabhängig und kann so reden wie mir der
Schnabel gewachsen ist und habe immer
eine Folge immer man inneren Kompass das
ist ganz wichtig der ist der konservativ
und da macht man sich natürlich bei
bestimmten Herrschaften keine Freude das
heißt die große Spitzenpolitik bleibt
ihnen dadurch auch verwehrt Minister
wird man so richtig so so ist es auch
der Listenplatz ja der war voll ich bin
das bewerbe ich jetzt zum zweiten Mal
beim ersten Mal hatte ich Platz 51 haben
mir gesagt wenn du erstmal einmal drin
bist dann dann kommst du weiter nach
vorne jetzt bin ich auf Platz 61
nein das ist aber so aber das muss jeder
für sich selbst klären also ich könnte
so nicht ich habe wenig der schleimt
sich am besten nach oben in der Politik
kann man das so platt sagen ja es gibt
auch wirklich richtig gute die auch
ihren Weg gehen auch die jungen Leute
die wir bei uns gerade haben die haben
echt eine ganz klasse Einstellung und
machen das selbst ich habe oft gesagt
durch das lieber sagt nein weil es gibt
ja unangenehme Themen da muss man noch
klare Farbe bekennen aber für mich ist
es ein ganz wichtiger Punkt dass man
authentisch ist und dann läuft sie auch
eigentlich ne und das haben wir zu wenig
gesagt das Klima dass sie beschreiben
ist ja auch sehr gefährlich in unserer
System Auseinandersetzung mit China ich
möchte das überhaupt nicht gleichsetzen
also hier wenn die Leute nicht ins
Gefängnis gehen gesperrt jahrelang und
auch gibt noch keine vollständige Zensur
des Internets oder sowas natürlich ist
das nicht vergleichbar nur es sollte ja
gerade die Stärke unseres Systems sein
dass sie auch ausstrahlen soll dass man
sagt bei uns kann man auch radikal
unterschiedliche Meinungen vertreten so
die Idee der Aufklärung auch wenn du die
völlig gegensätzliche Meinung von mir
heißt ich trete dafür ein dass du deine
Meinung sagen kannst und das hat ja
unser System stark gemacht im Vergleich
zu China wenn dieser Vorteil aber nicht
mehr da ist oder zumindest nicht mehr so
offenkundig da ist ist das für uns auch
ein großes Problem in der
Auseinandersetzung aber hier kommt ja
immer dass das Argument kommt ja immer
hier da noch einmal zu ihnen herbolz das
Argument kommt ja immer man kann seine
Meinung sagen wie man will da muss man
aber mit Widerspruch rechnen Michelle
Friedmann hat es letztens ganz groß
erzählt groß getönt jeder kann seine
Meinung sagen den Widerspruch muss man
aber ertragen was würden Sie denn diesem
Gegenargument was ja immer kommt
entgegnen das ist sehr sehr einfach man
muss nicht nur Widerspruch ertragen das
würde ja jeder gerne das wäre ja Streit
so wie wir ihn brauchen Argumente
bringen Thesen bringen
Antithesen Widerspruch das ertragen und
diskutieren aber das ist ja nicht das
was passiert sie kriegen nicht
Widerspruch sondern sie werden gecancelt
sie werden ausgeschlossen sie gehören
nicht mehr dazu sie werden auch eine
medienpranger gestellt sie sind ein
Außenseiter in Outcast das klassische
Beispiel bei uns in Deutschland ist der
Sarrazin ja also wenn man ein
klassisches Gegenargument genau in
diesem Sinne von Friedmann guckt euch
doch Sarrazin an diese der hat also
Millionen macht er mit seinen
riesengroßen Auflagen der ist Nummer
eins im Spiegel und und und aber was ist
der defacto der Fall er ist ein Outcast
es ist jemand der Polizeischutz braucht
wenn er auftritt das heißt er wird der
gehört nicht mehr zur guten Gesellschaft
in Deutschland und das ist ein Preis der
gigantisch groß ist und wenn sie nicht
so berühmt sind wie Sarrazin dann bleibt
Ihnen im Grunde nur die Tatsache dass
sie exkommuniziert sind aus der
Gemeinschaft der guten und das ist das
Schlimmste was einem in einer
Gesellschaft passieren kann wenn sie
nicht mehr dazu gehören wenn sie
ausgeschlossen werden
die Aufklärung angesprochen oder es ist
eine Dialektik der Aufklärung die
Aufklärung kippt in der Gegenteil es
sind ja die besonders tolerant die die
von sich denken sie seien tolerant die
dann besonders intolerant sind haben die
Akademie angesprochen die Universität
dass ich verstehe es auch dort nicht
also es gibt doch keinen grundfreien
Professor nicht seine Meinung sagt und
da habe ich das ganz stark erlebt oder
schlimm ist dann für mich wenn diese
Milieu übergreifen die intellektuelle
Kaste sind ob das Journalisten sind oder
Professoren oder Politik gemäß sind die
sind alle im gleichen Müll aufgewachsen
und die haben dann die gleichen Thesen
und dass das verstehe ich einfach nicht
dass man da nicht Freude hat dann
Auseinandersetzung und es wirklich so
die ja die die toleranten die die Links
toleranten die sind dann die die kommen
ganz stark mit Maulkörben kommen und da
kommt eben die Schere im Kopf die ich
angesprochen habe ich meine unglaublich
oder ein schöner Kinderfilm ein schönes
Kinderbuch und da kommt irgendeine
Spinner These von der kleinen Ecke und
das macht einen Verlag er sagt wir
ziehen die Bücher zurück es ist quasi
selbst Zensur das finde ich
unglaublichen Vorgang und das wird aber
noch lange erklärt da gibt es auch die
die kulturelle Aneignung da gab es in
der Schweiz zwei Fälle die wurden dann
europaweit auch diskutiert da waren
weiße Musiker die haben Reggae Musik
gespielt mit Dreadlocks und dann wurde
gesagt Konzert abgebrochen
also da haben wir wirklich fast alle die
den berichtet das geht nicht das setzt
sich trotzdem man heult ein bisschen auf
wenn sie auf der Straße Umfrage machen
wie er zu verbieten ich habe meine
columen darüber geschrieben ich habe
gehört du hast eine riesen wenn sie
Bevölkerung Frage ich bin überzeugt 99%
der Bevölkerung wird sagen die Spinnen
logisch wie Natur lesen aber es setzt
sich trotzdem in diesen Kreis neben die
Ton angeben sind durch es kommt beim
Start immer mehr es kommt bei den
Verlagen es kommt Bezeichnungen wir
bleiben noch einmal bei dem Beispiel mit
der cancel culture weil sie haben Recht
Winnetou da hat mein Herz auch geweint
aber wenn Menschen werden ist noch ein
bisschen schlimmer als Winnetou wenn er
gecantet wird aber da eine Frage an Sie
selbst die unpolitische schauspielerin
Jennifer anist die sich eigentlich
wirklich nicht politisch äußert hat hat
ein großes Interview gegeben vor kurzem
dass sie die cancel culture ängstigt da
ist vorne sehr überhaupt nicht betroffen
aber davon sind Männer in ihrer Branche
betroffen mir tun und so weiter was ich
mich frage wie weit sind wir denn schon
in Deutschland bei in Amerika ist es ja
im Vergleich schon viel größer die keine
gesellschaftlichen Auswirkungen auf uns
werden wir noch mehr steigen in der
känze culture wird zurückgehen wie
prognostizieren sie es für Deutschland
das ist sehr schwer zu prognostizieren
weil ich natürlich noch nicht bereit bin
zu sagen wie immer machen wir alles mit
zehn Jahren Verzögerung nach was die
Amerikaner vormachen sie haben
vollkommen recht der Zustand in Amerika
auch in England ist noch viel viel
schlimmer als bei uns trotzdem muss man
die walkness als eine sehr sehr
gefährliche kulturrevolutionäre Bewegung
begreifen ich kann Ihnen aber ganz kurz
erklären warum es so ist dass obwohl
viele nicht nur in den Medien auch
Politiker das absurd finden auch gegen
das genders sind also über 70% der
Bevölkerung ist gegen das Gendern viele
Politiker sind dagegen warum wird es
trotzdem gemacht und trotzdem
durchgesetzt oder solche Verrücktheiten
wie kulturelle Aneignung das ist ganz
einfach sie können sich klar machen bei
einem normalen wie soll man seine
Einladung zum Essen wo man damit rechnen
muss das Veganer dabei sind wenn die
wenn die dabei sind dann ist es einfach
eine Lebensklugheit zu sagen auch dann
lasst uns doch alles vegan machen denn
wenn sie etwas nicht veganes anbieten
gibt es einen riesenprozess der Veganer
die ganz wenige sind aber dem Protest
ist riesengroß während alle anderen die
wenn Sie sowohl noch normal essen dann
sagen naja gut macht nichts essen war
halt mal vegan kann nichts hören und
genauso ist es bei allen anderen wenn
sie Winnetou rausnehmen aus dem Programm
dann ersparen Sie sich die die
Wutattacken die hassattacken der
Aktivisten der wirken Aktivisten und die
anderen denken zwar sind die verrückt
aber kaufen trotzdem bei dem Verlag die
anderen Bücher weiter also das ist
einfach nur eine Kalkül taktisches
Kalkül zu sagen wie mache ich mir
möglichst wenig
Ärger mit diesen Aktivisten
Freiheit zu tun und damit kommen wir zu
Ihrem Thema Herr gut ja ich stelle
einfach fest dass die Freiheit bedroht
ist in unseren westlichen Ländern nicht
jetzt irgendwo in autoritären Staaten
und zwar vom Staat her
ich spreche von einer staatlichen
Ökodiktatur ich meine ich finde es
unglaublich weil der Staat vorschreibt
welches Antriebssystem ich beim Auto
benutzen soll oder wenn es plötzlich
heißt
2035 will die EU Verbrennungsmotoren
verbieten das finde ich einfach
inakzeptabel und wir plötzlich
vorgeschrieben wie viel man heizen darf
19 Grad oder 18 Grad 21 Grad es geht
durch den Staat nichts an und dass das
kommt immer mehr dass der Staat
Vorschriften macht und da finde ich eben
Deutschland schon auch nicht irgendwie
ein großartiges Vorbild die EU ist auch
sehr auf diesem autoritären trieb das
ist ein demokratisch nicht legitimiert
das Instrument auch die deutsche
Vorsitzende neo-kommission ist nicht
wirklich eine gewählte Person und die
bestimmte sehr viel und das kommt sehr
von oben herab und ich glaube das
obrigkeitliche denken das regt viele
Bürger auf die Freiheit der Bürger muss
gestärkt werden man muss von unten nach
oben regiert und nicht von oben herab
ein Schweizer liest uns die Leviten habe
ich so das Gefühl bei ihrer These aber
wenn ich sie fragen darf mit der
Obrigkeitshörigkeit geht die denn vom
Staat aus oder von den Bürgern selbst
nehmen wir die corona-maßnahmen da kam
es mir jetzt nicht so vor als müsste der
Staat jeden einzeln darauf hinweisen
viele Bürger waren auch gerne
quasi Impfzwang ein maskenvorschrift ich
meine ich habe das selbst erlebt in
Flugzeugen kulturellen Veranstaltung
kommt einfach nicht rein auf das schon
der Start der massiv einfällt aber
selbstverständlich braucht es immer zwei
bei einer materiellen Systems braucht
jemand der Befehle ausgibt und es gibt
es braucht die die dann gehorchen eben
nicht gehorchen aber ich finde schon das
ist vom Staat ein sehr autoritäres
denken gerade im Öko-Bereich ist das
unglaublich stark wieder eine Ideologie
im Hintergrund wo man sagt das ist das
Wahre und dann will man den Bürgen
vorschreiben wie sie zu leben haben und
das widersteht mir zutiefst auch als
Liberaler Mensch und ich glaube es geht
vielen in diesem Land ist auch so und ja
ich sage ich zeige gar nicht mit dem
Finger auf andere Länder ich finde
einfach diese Obrigkeit ich Tradition
die hat vielleicht in Deutschland auch
ein bisschen mehr Geschichte die Schweiz
ist da direkt demokratisch ein bisschen
anders aufgestellt aber diese Tendenz
gibt es auch bei uns ich meine Corona
war der Schweizer Bundesrat hat krasse
Vorschriften gemacht und viele haben
sich auch gedruckt und alle die sich
gewehrt haben als Spinne hingestellt
jetzt im Nachhinein muss man sagen okay
ja gut es gibt keine großen Studien die
Beleges die Masken so wirksam sind es
gibt auch sehr viele Fragezeichen bei
der Impfung die aus Heilmittel verkauft
worden ist obwohl sie ja nicht wirklich
getestet worden ist also viele dieser
sogenannten Spinnen haben auf der lange
Distanz Recht bekommen und da finde ich
schon dass das die Bürger eben als
kritisch sein müssen und das nicht
akzeptieren sollen wenn solche nicht
evidenzbasierten also nicht auf Fakten
und Erfahrung bei hohen Vorschriften vom
Staat kommen
Politiker sind wir Deutschen denn
obrigkeitshörig das glaube ich schon
aber wir sehen das ja in vielen
Bereichen das ja auch so diese
Mainstream Politik sehen wir ja nicht
nur in der Politik sondern in vielen
anderen wirtschaftlichen Bereichen man
fragt beim vegan ganz genauso wie sie es
auch gerade gesagt haben dann schenke
ich halt nur vegan aus aber es gibt ja
in vielen Bereichen diese diese Sache
dass man einfach etwas verfolgt und den
Widerspruch können wir nicht reden weil
sofort in die Ecke kommen es auch diese
Ziele die wir haben gerade im
Klimabereich die werden ja vorgegeben
man weiß eigentlich jetzt schon dass man
sie nicht erfüllen kann und dann schaut
man sich an den an den an den Praktikern
mal wendet ich sage jetzt noch mal
dieses Beispiel mit den Wärmepumpen die
sollen ich glaube 6 Millionen verbaut
werden bis 2030 und wir bräuchten dafür
60.000 Handwerker die haben wir nicht
und warum reduziere ich das hier das und
Wettbewerb auch bei den Parteien da
machen wir leider Gottes auch mit von
der CDU und dann weiß ich jetzt schon in
drei Jahren wir können es nicht erfüllen
und es wird von oben aber gesteuert sie
können aber auch nichts gegen sagen weil
sie sofort in die Ecke geschoben werden
und das ist ein riesen Problem Herr Bolz
sie haben ja schon gesagt sie sind
Pensionär sie können also ja einfach gut
auswandern sie sind aber noch hier
glauben sie noch an unser Land ja
selbstverständlich also ich glaube das
was man so neudeutsch resiliens nennt so
die Spannkraft die Reaktionsfähigkeit
von Deutschland vor allem der deutschen
Wirtschaft ist gewaltig das wäre auch
meine Antwort auf die Frage von vorhin
schaffen wir das mit den mit den
Flüchtlingen Deutschland hat so
unglaubliche Wirtschaftskraft nach wie
vor es ist unvorstellbar die können ja
das hat man aber jetzt schon vier fünf
mal gedacht bei Griechenland schon bei
bei der bei der aufkaufen der DDR immer
hat mal gesagt jetzt geht es nicht mehr
weiter so aber es geht Deutschland die
Sanktionen aus wir hatten es beim
Einstieg in die Sendung ich glaube das
schon also ich denke schon dass wir das
dass wir das schaffen
in diesem rein finanziellen Sinn
schaffen wir das alles was nicht heißt
dass wir das Problem lösen oder dass wir
mit dem Problem sinnvoll umgehen aber
ich denke in der Tat es ist so dass die
Deutschen mehr als andere Länder in
Europa
obrigkeitshörig sind also der der
Untertan von Heinrich Mann das ist immer
noch ein sehr aktuelles Buch und die
Deutschen werden eben ständig so wie
anderen Europäer auch aber sie reagieren
anders mit großem
Energiepreise absolut drin nicht alles
nur Untertan wir haben vollkommen recht
das die müssen ja dann auch mit diesem
Schicksal leben dass sie als Rechtsaußen
oder als Spinner oder als ewig Gestrige
behandelt werden aber ich denke die
Mehrheit der Deutschen wird doch von den
großen weltpolitischen Themen immer
angesprochen in den Registern Angst und
Sicherheit also man macht ihnen Angst
oder das was passiert macht ihnen Angst
und unsere Politik ist eine die ihnen
absolutes Sicherheit immer wieder
verspricht so dass wir meistens bereit
sind Freiheit für Sicherheit zu opfern
und das ist etwas was man an vielen
vielen Themen auch an Ukraine Krieg und
an alle
einhaken bei der Ukraine und ich dachte
mir wir können ja direkt mal Streit hier
am Tisch Proben ja wir sagen wir wollen
streiten ich ich vermute dass sie und
Herr gut eine ganz andere Meinung zu den
Wirtschaftssanktionen haben das vermute
ich jetzt einfach mal deswegen würde ich
da sie noch mal direkt bitten ob sie die
denn eigentlich für sinnvoll halten für
unser Land aber das die Antwort gebe ich
wirklich als krasser Laie ich weiß so
wenig von dem Ukraine Konflikt und ich
kenne die Ukraine nicht Russland auch
nicht ich habe nur wie jeder normale
Bürger eine Meinung und ein Gefühl und
mein Gefühl sagt mir es ist richtig die
Ukraine zu unterstützen es ist richtig
diese Wirtschaftssanktionen zu erheben
solange Sie uns nicht vollkommen
strangulieren jedenfalls also solange es
nicht in notwehrmaßnahmen aus sich
wirken muss trotzdem würde ich sagen und
das ist das für mein Thema ja auch
entscheidend wichtige Leute die das für
falsch halten die überhaupt unsere ganze
Ukraine Politik für falsch halten das
sind keine Spinner die sind nicht
verrückt sondern die haben einfach eine
andere Einschätzung einer extrem
komplexen Lage und ich glaube wir machen
uns vielen Themen nicht wirklich
deutlich wie komplex die Situationen
sind und wie laienhaft unser normales
Urteil eigentlich ist und dass wir
eigentlich ein vitales Interesse daran
haben müssten das kompetente Leute im
Streit uns verschiedene Aspekte eines
Themas entwickeln
nein ich Subvention sehe ich schon ein
bisschen anders ich meine das wurde aus
als grosses Instrument ganz stark tönend
oder von der EU da propagiert und wenn
ich einfach sehe wie es funktioniert
muss ich sagen es hat nicht das gebracht
was man sich davon versprochen hat immer
diese nüchterne Kosten Nutzenanalyse
muss ja wohl noch möglich sein und ich
sehe einfach zum Beispiel schauen Sie
Gastraum an erstes Halbjahr 2022 Rekord
Erlebnis die haben noch nie so viel
verdient mit Export von Gas und Öl da
muss auch sagen irgendwo sind diese
Subventionen nicht das was man sich
davon gesprochen hat innerhalb der Welt
kann man das Exportieren anderen Ländern
ist das Furz egal was da passiert das
ist
aufgeladene Politik man denkt er muss
irgendwas entgegensetzen aber muss
nachschauen was nützt das und wenn es am
Ende so ist dass es es gibt Leute in
Russland ich habe es letztendlich
Sendung in Österreich erzählt habe ich
auch gefärbt dafür ich wiederhole es
gerne zu dieser Meinung geben stehe die
Leute dort die Leben von einer Pension
von rund 200 € im Monat und dann müsste
alles bezahlen Medikamente es gibt keine
Krankenkassen nichts und wenn jetzt eine
ältere Dame die davon lebt ihr es jetzt
betroffen zum Beispiel Geldtransfers das
ist nötig das Verwandte Bekannte hier in
Westeuropa Geld schickt das ist nicht
mehr erlaubt was einfacher wirk ich muss
kein oligarc sein ich kann nicht einen
beliebigen Russen Geld überweisen Moment
das ist doch einfach krank da muss man
sagen pack den Putin das ist ein
Aggressor der hat ein Verbrechen
begangen nämlich Angriffskrieg das ist
völkerrechtlich gerecht da bin ich
völlig bei Ihnen oder vermutlich bei
allen hier am Tisch aber es geht nicht
dass man dann einfach solche mit der
Streumunition quasi mit der Schrotflinte
da Subventionen es Sanktionen macht die
einfach auch die das ist momentan der
Fall und das muss man auch sehen konnte
noch hinzu was passiert eigentlich hier
wenn Du uns am Schluss so stark ins
eigene Fleisch schneiden dass wir im
Winter verlieren dass wir unsere
wirtschaftsrunde geht weil wir keine
E-Mail haben dann lacht sie der Putin
doppelt ins Feuer da muss man schon
sagen das ist nicht der der Weisheit
letzter Schluss was wir da haben aber
ich meine es wäre ja absolut
heuchlerisch wenn man zum einen Angst
davor hätte schwere Waffen zu liefern um
nicht den Krieg total eskalieren zu
lassen wenn man zum anderen sich
ausdrücklich für die Sache der Ukraine
aussprechen würde also Solidarität mit
der Ukraine proklamiert und dann aber
mit Russland Handel treibt wie eh und je
ohne irgendein Alter das wäre keine
Heuchelei ich gebe Ihnen ja zu dass
diese Wirtschaft Sanktionen viel weniger
wirken oder vielleicht völlig unwirksam
sind ich glaube aber nicht dass das so
vollkommen überraschend kommt für die
Politiker sondern diese
Wirtschaftssanktionen haben auch glaube
ich eine große symbolische Bedeutung
das ist genau das Stichwort ist da also
würde ich tippen Fehlern Platz aber wie
sehen Sie das Herr dohrendorf ich meine
hier die die es wurde ja gesagt die
Politik hat das einkalkuliert glauben
sie das auch dass die Wirksamkeit bzw
die fehlende Wirksamkeit naja ist halt
ein bisschen schwierig also man musste
auf jeden Fall reagieren das hat man ja
einen anderen Stellen leider nicht
gemacht in vielen Bereichen und Putin
der testet einfach nur aus das sind
Adresse der sieht seine Macht und wer da
wer da nicht gegen geht da hat er keine
hat er keine Chance zieht er seine
Sachen durch also das hat man sicherlich
ein bisschen mit einkalkuliert aber man
musste natürlich auch etwas machen das
was sie sagen es kann nicht sein dass
man sich beschwert aber dann Handel
betreibt sondern da muss natürlich etwas
kommen ob es wirksam ist wie sie es
gesagt haben es ist mit Fragezeichen zu
zu behaften aber man muss auf jeden Fall
reagieren die Menschen in ihrem
Wahlkreis weil wenn man jetzt zum
Beispiel auch aktuelle Umfragen anschaut
die Deutschen sind jetzt nicht alle für
die Sanktion nein aber ich muss ganz
ehrlich sagen wir haben natürlich sehr
viele jetzt in Deutschland fast eine
Million Ukrainer bei uns sind auch sehr
viele bei uns muss ich sagen wir haben
guten Kontakt mit denen und wenn sie
natürlich die Schilderungen bekommen wie
sie dort behandelt worden ist was die
erlebt haben haben sie einen ganz
anderes Verständnis als wenn sie noch
mal ab und zu einer Zeitung lesen was
weit weg ist da sind wir schon sehr bei
den Ukrainern und versuchen dort zu
helfen und können das auch ein Stück
weit verstehen ganz klar ist es in
Ordnung mit der wirtschaftssanktion
Herr geig ist wie blicken Sie darauf ich
meine sie sind wahrscheinlich der hier
der am meisten Einblick auch in die
Außenpolitik in anderen Ländern hat man
kann ja schon sagen dass Russland und
China immer enger auch jetzt dadurch
zusammenrücken können wir Deutsch
überhaupt was ausrichten auf jeden Fall
und das ist genau der Punkt also was
mich stört ist dass es hier viel zu sehr
aus der deutschen und europäischen
Brille gesehen wird und so getan wird
als ob die ganze Welt jetzt Russland
verurteilen würde und das ist ja leider
muss man sagen nicht so sondern wir
haben eine Situation wie wir es hier
noch nie hatten auf der Welt dass China
ein wirtschaftlich absolut mächtiges
Land geworden ist ganz anders als in der
Zeit des Kalten Krieges wo die
Sowjetunion wie Helmut Schmidt damals
sagte oberwolter mit Atomraketen
militärisch stark aber wirtschaftlich
überhaupt nicht jetzt haben wir mit
China ein wirtschaftlich ganz starkes
Land und anders als in der Zeit wo
beides sehr viel schwächer waren sind ja
China und russ heute zusammen damals
waren ja
Sowjetunion und China hat sich ja
verkracht und das hatte dann nächsten
genutzt um China mehr oder weniger auf
die Seite des Westen zu ziehen jetzt
sind die beiden zusammen China freut
sich natürlich über das Öl dass sie
jetzt aus Russland beziehen also ich bin
völlig bei ihnen Putin Agressor wir
müssen überlegen was wir machen und was
auch was bringt aber wir sollten uns
nicht der Illusion hingeben dass wir da
so stark sein sondern es formt sich da
ein Block der wirtschaftlich stark ist
und der von der Bevölkerungszahl her
auch viel viel größer ist als wir alle
zusammen der messen und darüber sprechen
wir gleich nach einer ganz kurz
Unterbrechung sprechen wir darüber ob
China eigentlich aktuell der lachende
Dritte ist bis gleich
[Musik]
ernst nehmen als sogenannten Experten
herzlich willkommen meine Damen und
Herren bei viertel nach acht fünf Köpfen
fünf Meinungen von jeder von uns hat ein
Thema mitgebracht dass sie bewegt ärgert
freut oder schockiert
so nicht Privatchat Uschi Jürgen
aber niemand von dem politischen
Parteien traut sich zu sagen ja das
wollen wir einfach nur Freiheit diese
grün-roten stehen da und führen
hochtrabende Debatten über die Rettung
des Weltklimas und um die Füße rum wo
sollen die Ratten das Thema ist viel zu
wichtig uns nur der AFD zu überlassen
lass den Leuten noch mal den Spaß wir
sehen da etwas was eigentlich fatal ist
in der Politik bei den Journalisten
deren Job ist es doch gerade abweichende
Meinungen zu finden und sie sollen den
doch auch richtig doof finden
zu Manko vielleicht einmal kurz an das
Auto
das sind irgendwelche anorakträger aus
Buxtehude die das Gucken so ich habe
mein Beifall in meine lache immer
bekommen wer kümmert sich darum niemand
bitte ja man muss da ganz klar jetzt mal
auch darüber sprechen dass es einfach
nicht fair ist und nicht richtig Aufgabe
von Journalismus einfach die die
Verlautbarung der Politik zu
hinterfragen
[Musik]
wir sind zurück schön dass Sie dran
geblieben sind und jetzt sprechen wir
über die Grünen und wie man eigentlich
deren aktuellen Job zu bewerten könnte
und das macht Herr dorundorf ja Robert
Habeck ist der unfähigste
Wirtschaftsminister in der Geschichte
Deutschlands warum sage ich das also wer
im Fernsehen sagt dass ein Bäcker nur
mal zwei drei Monate nicht produzieren
muss und es passiert ja nichts also der
kann es nicht wir brauchen nicht über
die Pendlerpauschale sprechen die hat er
ja auch mal wunderbar erklärt oder nicht
erklärt und ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen
wir haben ein Energie und ein
Wirtschaftskrieg ja den Leuten geht es
schlecht und er führt Sandkastenspiele
durch das heißt anstatt wirklich jede
klimastunde zu nutzen jedes
Atomkraftwerk jedes Kohlekraftwerk die
Chinesen Bauten dieses Jahr 300
Kohlekraftwerke und wir sträuben uns
alles zu nutzen damit wir diese
Energiekrise auch überwinden die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger werden frieren
und die Grünen haben Schuld das müssen
sie nur wissen und ich finde es
unsäglich dass auch der
Ministerpräsident in Niedersachsen weil
damit sie und sagt ja Niedersachsen
geht's gut aber was mit den anderen
Bundesländern ist interessiert ihn
eigentlich gar nicht und das ist so
schade und wir werden sehen wenn die
Wahlen am Sonntag vorbei sind wird auch
das AKW in Niedersachsen wieder mit
reinkommen aber ich finde es halt total
unsichtlich weil so funktioniert es eben
nicht Herr dohrendorf the pioneer des
median Startup von Gabor man kann auch
mit den Firmen die haben mir letztens im
Pioneer Briefing auch geschrieben er war
der Star der deutschen Wirtschaft wann
war er habe ich denn eigentlich der Star
der deutschen Wirtschaft das habe ich
mich direkt gefragt beim lesen weil sie
sagen jetzt unfähig der
Wirtschaftsminister in Deutschland die
Mainz hatte hat die Wirtschaft denen so
sehr gefeiert sie sind selbstunternehmer
also ich kann das nicht so empfinden er
war bei den damenkammer sehr gut an ja
aber ich muss auch ganz ehrlich sagen
was man jetzt hört ja wir haben 2000
Mitarbeiter im Ministerium
Wirtschaftsministerium und auch ein Eier
hat den ein oder anderen Kopf mal
entlassen und einen neuen besetzt aber
was habe ich jetzt gerade gemacht hat er
hat die die die Ökonomen die
Wirtschaftswissenschaftler alle
entlassen und hat jetzt neue Leute drauf
gesetzt seine Leute nabus Bund aus den
aus dem Windkraft Energie
Seiteneinsteiger die brauchen wir
garantiert nicht sondern wir brauchen
wirklich wissenschaftliche fachliche
Expertise im Vergleich zu setzen
beispielsweise Finanzminister Christian
Lindner hat die auch behalten erstmal
die aus dem alten Ministerium Robert
Habeck anscheinend hat aber gedacht er
könnte es besser alle raus da muss ihn
keiner zumindest da machen wenn sie
jetzt aber der Berater von Harbeck wenn
es ich weiß es relativ schwierig sie
haben gesagt er ist sehr unfähigste
Wirtschaftsminister in Deutschland
jemals hatte aber wenn sie jetzt der
Berater werden würden sie noch den Kurs
schaffen habe ich umzudrehen was müsste
er jetzt tun nein ich würde es nicht
schaffen also da habe ich wirklich da
habe ich keine Hoffnung ich muss auch
ganz ehrlich sagen auch die Grünen
insgesamt ja auch diese Dame die ja auch
immer überall so schön im Fernsehen ist
die Erwachsene der Grünen genau acht
Jahre studiert oder sieben Jahre nie
etwas gearbeitet nie gelernt das hat man
auch bei anderen Parteien aber das mag
sein aber ich kritisiere das bei unseren
Parteien ganz genauso aber solche Leute
sind bei uns jetzt an der Macht und
sollen Deutschland führen nein und dann
sehen Sie diese Verlogenheit ja ich sage
jetzt nur mal die die Prämie in der
corner Prämie die die wirklich gestaltet
wurden war um Kassiererin Polizisten
oder auch die im Homeoffice Arbeiten zu
unter finanziell zu unterstützen und die
die die die der der Bundesvorstand
genehmigt sich selbst diese größte 1500
€ einmalig diese Bonuszahlung auch wenn
es nachher zurückgezahlt haben ist doch
verlogen da kann man doch nur sehen den
geht's nur ums Geld leider und um reine
Ideologie denn das was sie vor zehn
Jahren mal gesagt haben da kommen sie ja
jetzt langsam hin hier frage ich einmal
gerne Herrn Bolt scheitern die Grünen
denn jetzt in ihren eigenen Ansprüchen
weil wenn man an die Grünen denkt denkt
man ja eigentlich an Grün und keine
Atomkraftwerke Kohlekraftwerke auch
schon gar nicht scheitern die Grünen
jetzt an den eigenen insofern ist die
Zeit in der wir im Augenblick Leben
wirklich wahnsinnig spannend weil die
beiden fundamentalen Ideologie mit der
Grünen jetzt auf dem Prüfstand sind
Pazifismus und eben
antiatomkraft beides im Grunde müsste
überdacht werden oder müsste vollkommen
neu gedacht werden von den Grünen sie
werden es aber und das deshalb teile ich
ins Skepsis niemals tun weil das auch
ihr Gründungsmythos ist ihre Identität
ausmacht denn die Grünen sind keine
politische Partei sondern sie sind eine
religiöse Sekte und das erklärt auch
warum es ihre Anhänger bei Ihnen bleiben
selbst wenn alles den Bach runter geht
also sie werden immer diese 15 Prozent
bekommen selbst wenn
wirtschaftlich immer immer schlimmer
wird weil es bei den Grünen um Themen
geht die mit Wirtschaftspolitik oder so
gar nicht einzuholen sind die da gar
nicht diskutiert werden können das sind
Themen die wie soll man sagen
metaphysisch sind oder wirklich
theologisch sind und die im Grunde etwas
zu tun haben auch mit dieser Vorstellung
wir das kleine Deutschland also diese
wenigen Leute die hier leben wir könnten
Vorbild sein für die ganze Welt und wir
könnten die Welt retten wir könnten im
Grunde vorangehen dass er jedes
Lieblingswort dieser Leute wir gehen
voran in der Hoffnung dass uns die ganze
Welt folgt das ist ein das ist ein
messian ja es ist freundlich formuliert
eigentlich ist es sogar eine Art
missionarisches Bewusstsein ja nur wir
sehen klar auch im Blick auf den Rest
von Europa von der ganzen restlichen
Welt ganz zu schweigen wir sind die
einzigen die die Probleme richtig sehen
rätselhafter Weise folgen uns die
anderen noch nicht aber wir müssen
weitergehen das ist mehr oder nein
ich habe einen Großteil meines Lebens im
Ausland gelebt und diese ja wie sie
sagen zu dieser missionarische Eifer und
dieser Glaube so wir haben so die die
heilsidee
hat ja auch wie man weiß zu sehr
schlimmen Sachen in der Geschichte führt
was ich jetzt überhaupt nicht mit den
Grünen gleichsetzen möchte keinesfalls
aber das ist schon sehr typisch für für
uns oder für sehr viele Deutsche also
Menschen woanders auf der Welt sind da
oft sehr sehr viel pragmatischer einfach
ich finde schon spannend Leute die Frage
sehr aufgeworfen haben wird jetzt die
Grünen eigentlich demaskiert oder werden
die Wähler jetzt aber rücken sie
verneinen das ich finde es eigentlich
interessant weil sind ja eigentlich
extrem links und lange hat man eben
gedacht ja gut wenn man nicht unbedingt
links will aber grün das geht das ist
die Umweltschutz klar gut ich ich teile
Ihre Auffassung insofern das wirklich
religiöse Züge hat aber es geht über die
Grünen hinaus ich meine die ganze Klima
der Klima war wie ich sagen das ist auch
eine Klima Religion das ist unglaublich
man muss an diesen Glaubenssatz denken
ich erinnere mich da komme ich zurück
auf ihre These dass wir nicht mehr offen
diskutiert vor fünf oder zehn Jahren
habe ich noch ernsthaft diskutiert ja
Klimawandel Mensch gemacht ja nein wenn
es gemacht müsste man sagen wie groß ist
das ist vollkommen aus Diskussion
verschwunden wie wir denken gar nicht
mehr darüber nach wie sagen nur noch das
sind die Klimaziele die müssen
vielleicht und jetzt kommt eben das das
grüne und das autoritäre kommen ganz
gefährlich zusammen da kommt eben der
Vater statt da bin ich immer meine These
wieder Freiheit einschränken du darfst
nicht Autofahren dein Porsche muss in
der Garage bleiben ganz schlimm du musst
auf das Velo umsteigen und da kann man
über die absurden Widersprüche dann eben
dass man jetzt merkt ah okay Kernkraft
ist vielleicht doch sie eigentlich doch
lieber freundlich ist eigentlich gut
oder jetzt wieder Kohle anstellen das
ist dermaßen widersprüchlich und
eigentlich müsste jeder jetzt entdecken
und sagen nein diese Politik das geht
nicht aus gehen wir zurück zur Vernunft
seine vernünftigen bürgerlichen
liberalen Politik aber ich glaube auch
ich sehe sowieso ich bin das skeptisch
dass das große Wachen kommt das Leiden
muss offenbar noch viel größer sein
nicht der halsbringer ist das sieht man
ja an China und daher Moment kommen wir
zu These von Ihnen Herr Geiger ja Ende
nächster Woche beginnt der Parteitag der
Kommunistischen Partei Chinas und es ist
davon auszugehen dass cheating Ping dort
zum Diktator auf Lebenszeit gekrönt wird
das gab es noch nie in der Geschichte
dass ein Mensch ein Mensch mit derart
absoluter macht ein wirtschaftlich so
starkes Land geführt hat und damit ist
unser aller Freiheit gefährdet und wir
müssen sagen leider leider hatte
Deutschland ein entscheidenden Anteil
gehabt das ist so weit gekommen ist als
andere westliche Politiker schon davor
gewarnt haben war es Angela Merkel die
immer für einen weichen Kurs gegenüber
China eintrat aus kurzfristigen
Profitinteressen haben volkswagen
Daimler Benz Siemens und viele andere
ein Großteil ihrer Produktion nach China
verlagert und so das kommunistische
Regime dort stark
ich bin nun überhaupt nicht dafür da
jetzt nichts symbolischen
symbolischen Sanktionen zu machen die im
Zweifel uns mehr Schaden als Schichten
Ping aber was wir machen müssen ist
endlich wieder unsere eigene
industrielle basisausbauen selber
Computerchips produzieren selber
medizinische Geräte produzieren um so
unsere totale Abhängigkeit hier noch
viel größer ist als die Abhängigkeit von
Russland die totale Abhängigkeit von
China entscheiden zu reduzieren nicht
kein Handel mehr mit China zu betreiben
klar ist ein großes Land mit dem man
Handel treiben muss aber unsere totale
Abhängigkeit entscheidend zu reduzieren
das klingt sehr dramatisch sind wir im
Endeffekt wenn ich sie richtig verstehen
noch abhängiger von China als von
Russland total also alles das haben wir
jetzt während der corona-krise erlebt
von den Masken bis zu dem
Beatmungsgeräten ist kommt alles aus
China und wir sind noch umgekehrt
abhängig weil eben ich habe zum Beispiel
Volkswagen das gilt aber für die anderen
Autounternehmen genauso sich
die haben gedacht ja klar großer Markt
1,4 Milliarden Menschen aber sich damit
so abhängig gemacht haben dass diese
Autounternehmen pleite wären wenn jetzt
zum Beispiel China Taiwan angreift und
wir dann uns entscheiden genauso China
zu boykottieren wie weit Russland
boykottieren während diese
Autounternehmen pleite und damit ein
Rückgrat der deutschen Industrie aber
kommen wir noch mal zum ukraine-konflikt
ist China da der lachende Dritte auf
jeden Fall weil also Chinas oder das
gemeinsame Ziel von cheating pinken
putin ist ja die Weltordnung zu
verändern und ja wie sie sagen die die
westliche Vorherrschaft zu brechen aber
damit meinen Sie natürlich auch die
Vorstellungen von Freiheit Demokratie
und so weiter dass die nicht mehr als
nachahmenswertes Modell in der Welt
gelten sollen sondern ihre eigene Art
von
Regierungsführung und aber selbst wenn
selbst wenn
Putin verlieren sollte was nicht im
Sinne von Chichi Ping wäre aber selbst
dann ich meine das sind doch wir die die
jetzt frieren sind ja nicht die Chinesen
die haben ihre eigenen Probleme
sicherlich aber was das angeht wird
durch diesen Konflikt der Westen weiter
entscheiden geschwächt egal wie der
Konflikt ausgeht und chiching Ping ist
der lachender dritte da muss ich schon
sagen ich teile diese Einschätzung oder
dass da eine starke Achse auch
heranwächst egal wie eng die dann
zusammenarbeiten aber das sind Systeme
die unser Bestes System gegenüberstehen
aber ich möchte auch wissen daran
erleben dass wir auch selbstkritisch
sein müssen im Westen wenn ich finde das
schon nach unglaublich wenn jetzt wenn
Sie die ganzen Konflikte da ansprechen
auch Ukraine Kriege oder die man hat
schon einfach sehr unvorsichtig das
gemacht ich meine jetzt kann man schon
sagen ja gut böse Putin der böse schien
die Chinese oder aber wenn ich mir
überlege was ist in den letzten Jahren
passiert ich war da auch meine bei mai
down bei diesen großen Demonstrationen
2014 bevor sie diesen äh ja diese
Explosion start-steich gegeben hat mit
klitschka hinzu gemacht dann auf den
Straßen das war schon da die
amerikanische Botschaft herum gelaufen
die haben mit demonstriert ich meine das
war schon ein extremer Druck die die
Nato ostenweitung hat man hat eine
russischen Bären auch provoziert und
natürlich ist das ein Problem
da möchte ich einmal die Meinung der
anderen beiden Herren in der Runde ist
ja schon eine sehr steile These hier am
Tisch hier ist ja alles erlaubt alles
erlaubt hier aber da muss ich natürlich
noch mal eine andere Meinung einholen
der Dorendorf wie sehen Sie das haben
wir den russischen Bären provoziert naja
also putin war hier hat im Reichstag mal
gesprochen ist ja schon paar Jahre her
hat man eigentlich gesagt dass man nicht
weitergeht man ist aber weitergegangen
man hat es versprochen und hat
versprochen
eigentlich etwas stärker in
wirtschaftlichen Bereichen integrieren
das hat man eigentlich auch nicht getan
rechtfertigt nicht den Angriff zu
Ukraine das ist gar keine Frage aber es
ist nicht so einfach wie man immer denkt
ne sondern man hätte wenn man ihn damals
stärker eingebunden hätte in diese
wirtschaftlichen Bereiche die man ja
auch eigentlich angesagt hatte und wenn
man nicht weiter gegangen wäre es
vielleicht genauso gewesen war der Krim
hat man ja auch schon das war ja sein
erster Test sage ich jetzt mal einfach
so
da hätte man einfach ein bisschen
Schicksale reagieren die westlichen
Mächte wie gehen sie darauf ein sind wir
drauf ein oder lassen wir es laufen das
war ja alles diese ganze also richtig
wir haben ja nicht viel gemacht
zu seiner These und zwar Russland die
Lage ist jetzt wie sie ist das muss man
jetzt so sagen die Spekulation ob man
mit Russland hätte anders verhandeln
können die helfen uns gerade leider
nicht mehr weiter mit China ist die Lage
auch wie sie ist sind sie denn trotzdem
frohen Mutes wenn sie auf die
Handelsbeziehung zwischen Deutschland
und China blicken
also
das ist wir haben diese Abhängigkeit und
diese Abhängigkeit wirklich jetzt
zunehmend politisch aus weil was die
meisten Leute nicht begreifen ist wie
sich China verändert hat mit heating
damals und seinen Nachfolgern oder von
ihm eingesetzten Leuten hat China sich
zur Welt geöffnet und war sehr
pragmatisch
mittlerweile unterschiedlichen ping geht
es wieder vor allem um Ideologie und
schicking Ping würde machen was seine
Vorgänger nicht gemacht hätten diese
wirtschaftliche Abhängigkeit die wir
haben ausnutzen wenn es um politische
Interessen geht da gibt es bereits viele
Beispiele dafür als Litauen eine
Vertretung von Taiwan aufgemacht hat
wurde das Land Litauen aus dem
Chinesischen zollverzeichnis gestrichen
das heißt es existiert nicht mehr das
betrifft jetzt nicht nur Litauen sondern
betrifft alle Firmen aus der ganzen Welt
die Einzelteile haben in ihren Produkten
aus Litauen die nicht mehr liefern weil
die in dem Zoll Verzeichnis nicht mehr
vorkommen als Bücher Botin chinesischer
Resident im Friedensnobelpreis bekommen
hat hat sich China entschieden keinen
Lachs mehr aus Norwegen zu kaufen also
chiching Ping ist entschlossen seine
wirtschaftliche Macht für seine
politisch ideologischen Zwecke zu nutzen
und darum müssen wir uns mit diesem Mann
beschäftigen und wissen wer er ist damit
wäre jetzt nicht ganz so düster aus der
Sendung rausgehen weil erst hatten wir
Deutschland kennen sie culture Atomkrieg
ich kann heute gar nicht mehr schlafen
deswegen würde ich die Herren einmal
bitten dass jeder ich fange bei ihnen
mal an Herrn Dorendorf sie mal etwas
Positives sagen warum sie positiv in die
Zukunft blicken dass wir heute mal mit
etwas Optimismus worin Deutschland gut
ist ins Ende gehen ich glaube einfach
die Situation die wir jetzt haben die
erdet uns ja auch auf der anderen Seite
wir waren ja auf einem ganz hohen Niveau
fallen jetzt gerade ein bisschen tiefer
und glaube ich kommt zu der alten Stärke
dass wir einfach das hoffe ich und das
glaube ich auch dass wir die Ärmel
hochkrämpfen will da müssen wir
natürlich einiges noch ändern Leist muss
sich wieder lohnen arbeit muss sich
lohnen wenn ich so ein Bürgergeld habe
und ich brauche nichts mehr machen und
die die Leute die so an der Schwelle
arbeiten wenn davon bestraft so geht sie
sagen Erdung jeder hat einen Konsistenz
was sagen sie Erdung ist schon weg ist
erdet uns die Krise was sagen Sie also
ich bin einfach deshalb optimistisch
weil ich nach wie vor der deutschen
Wirtschaft unglaubliche Fähigkeiten zu
schreibe ich habe immer wieder gehört
über Jahrzehnte hinweg Deutschland ist
am Abgrund und das geht bergab und immer
wieder hat sich Deutschland aufgrund
nicht der Politik wohlgemerkt mit der
Politiker das gar nichts zu tun sondern
aufgrund der unglaublichen Leistungen
der des Mittelstandes und der großen
Unternehmen Deutschland und darauf
vertraue ich nach wie vor und ich
vertraue auch darauf dass weil wir auch
über kulturelle Probleme gesprochen
haben dass im Grunde der Wahnsinn mit
dem wir es heute zu tun haben der
wooknis heißt oder Politik korrectness
dass er implodiert ich denke nämlich das
ist so weit getrieben das ist so weit in
die Verrücktheit hineingetrieben
das auf Dauer nicht zu halten ist und
das irgendwann eine junge Generation
nachwächst die wir das skeptisch ist und
die wieder auch Lust hat zu arbeiten und
ein blöd zu arbeiten das muss ja ein
bisschen zu einer anregen sie haben
jeder leider nur noch einen Satz was
gibt ihnen Hoffnung ich glaube der
Mensch der findungsreichtum ich glaube
ja die menschliche Vernunft an die
menschliche Schaffenskraft an die
menschen die Leidenschaft und wir werden
auch das hinkriegen die Politiker die
ihr jetzt nicht schaffen aber die
Menschen die normalen Bürger die werden
es schaffen meine optimistische these es
gibt einen Menschen der gefährlich
werden kann das ist schicking Ping
selbst bei der natürlich mit seiner
Politik auch China selbst schade der
chinesischen Wirtschaft und so das
Gegenteil erreichen kann möglicherweise
im Endeffekt von dem was er möchte
nämlich China Schwächen und das wäre
wiederum also das kommunistische China
Schwächen das wäre wiederum gut für uns
und damit sind wir am Ende angekommen
und Sie sehen es gibt noch viel
Optimismus in diesem Land schönen Abend
und bis morgen Abend tschüss machen sie
es gut
[Musik]